ja ich bin tatsächlich im zuge der
ukraine krise häufig gefragt worden ich
bin mit merkel ja häufig dort gewesen
wir haben auch gemeinsame auftritte von
merkel und putin beobachtet ist der irre
er sieht aufgedunsen aus ist ja physisch
angeschlagen was sein vorgehen erklären
würde ist er mental nicht auf der höhe
oder tickt aus und so weiter die
einfache antwort ist nein
manfred vits der große publizist hat man
ein gutes buch geschrieben irre wir
sperren die falschen 1 in den in der
psychiatrie sitzen die ihnen die
depressionen haben die große probleme
haben die andere verletzen würden kleine
fische im vergleich zu den diktatoren
der zeitgeschichte stalin und hitler hat
man auch immer gefragt sind die irre
nein sie sind nicht irre sie sind auf
eine teuflische art und weise
intelligent und genial das sieht man an
dem kalten strategischen vorgehen von
putin ich will ihn nicht dämonisieren
das ganze hat ein fast schon
folgerichtige szenario wir müssen uns
klarmachen im vergangenen sommer als der
besten hals über kopf aus afghanistan
abziehen konnte alle welt sehen der
westen ist nicht einmal in der lage eine
stammesgesellschaft in einem fiat welt
land irgendwie unter kontrolle zu halten
wenig später gab es die wahl in
deutschland mit einem klaren sieg für
die ampel koalition und für putin der
den westen und seinen dekadenten
lebensstil verachtet war das das signal
eines der wichtigsten länder in zentral
europa hat eine regierung mit einem
hohen idealistischen regierungsanteil
den grünen und sozialdemokraten was von
der fdp hält weiß man so genau nicht und
an der stelle begann die aufrüstung an
den grenzen der ukraine
es war ganz klar und dass wir testen
würde wie stark ist dieser westen her
war in afghanistan schwach zeigt jetzt
regierungsbildung in deutschland neben
frankreich der einzigen zentralmacht
frankreich ist gerade in den wahlen wie
stark ist dieser westen der in
sonntagsreden wenn man gern behauptet
europa müsse geostrategisch an gewicht
gewinnen ist dann aber am ende doch
wegen zerstrittenheit geschafft genau
das fordert er heraus dass testet er
denn putin weiß ganz genau seine stärke
an der weltgeschichte ist nur zusichern
wenn er so ein gerät ins geschehen das
haben wir in syrien gesehen dass die
anderen sich abarbeiten müssen dass man
an ihm nicht vorbei kommt dass er
vielleicht der böse bube ist aber an ihm
kommt man halt nicht vorbei
wirtschaftlich kann in den westen nicht
nieder konkurrieren wirtschaftlich ist
china stärker er testet den besten
einfach auf eine schulhof
rabauken art er haut einfach mal einen
nachbarn rein dann gibt es natürlich
noch diese tatsächlich nicht zu
unterschätzende historische komponente
all das kommt bei ihm zusammen es ist
alles sehr rational man kann nicht sagen
dass er blind würdigte einschlägt und
auch seine strategie die wir jetzt gern
belächelt ist nicht ganz schlecht er hat
nicht die mittel das land zu überrennen
er versucht es nicht mehr lebenswert zu
machen zu entvölkern
die menschen dort so lange zu zu quälen
wie sie selbst flüchten und er das land
leer übernehmen kann das alles folgt
einer strategie bitte unterschätzen wir
putin nicht
abwaschbare ist der vergleich dass putin
ein irrer ist und ja auch der selber in
einem satz genannt wie hitler ist das
übertrieben oder es putin ein diktator
nein
ich glaube ist ein diktator ein despot
er war noch nie ein lupenreiner demokrat
er war immer schon ein lupenreiner das
boot aber das heißt doch nicht also
folgt ist manfred lutz ist das richtige
stichwort ich hatte genau vor einer
woche die gelegenheit mit ihm mit
manfred lütz psychiater und bestseller
autor über eine putin zu sprechen im
rahmen unseres podcasts ist die wochen
tester und original zitat manfred lütz
der ist schrecklich normal
er hat das was jetzt geschieht über
jahre hinweg strategisch geplant und
vorbereitet und diese gleichung machen
wir sehr oft auf wir sagen es passiert
etwas unbegreifliches etwas
unmenschliches der muss ja verrückt sein
nein sagt er mittelschule oder
rollschuhen damit manfred nützt der ist
nicht verrückt da ist völlig er ist
völlig normal dass die banalität des
bösen und
dann kam noch der satz kann ich mich
noch gut erinnern
hütet euch vor den normalen
paul herr bosbach hat gerade noch mal
festgestellt bleibe ich mir putin ist
kein lupenreiner demokrat und wie gehen
wir denn jetzt um mit einem menschen wie
wladimir putin mit einem menschen der so
tickt und wer bei schlag gesagt hat der
ist ja eigentlich alle strategisch
geplant hatte langer hand
ja ich gebe
wolfgang bosbach und ralf schuler recht
in dem sinne dass wir schwach waren und
dass er das geplant hat aber ob das
jetzt wirklich strategisch so genial
geplant war da habe ich doch meine
zweifel wenn wir uns die
geheimdienstberichte anschauen und
wladimir putin vor hatte innerhalb von
tagen vielleicht hier in diesem zimmer
zu sitzen wo ich gerade sitze in kiew
und seinen sieg zu verkünden eine hätte
sich wahrscheinlich was pompöses
vorgestellt aber es ist ja so dass diese
dieser krieg wir verläuft für wladimir
putin eben nicht so verläuft wie er sich
vorgestellt hat er wurde mutmaßlich von
seinen fsb leuten ja sehr geblendet
informiert darüber was den zustand
seiner eigenen armee angeht aber auch
was den widerstand hier in der ukraine
angeht und was den willen der menschen
angeht
sozusagen ins russische reich
zurückzukommen wenn wir uns anschauen
das selbst in städten wie person also
näher richtung russland die menschen auf
die straße gehen mit ukrainischen
flaggen und sagen nein wir wollen das
nicht dann sieht man ja wie schwierig
das für ihn werden würde hier wirklich
das land zu kontrollieren
ich gebe ralf recht es könnte sein dass
sein seine strategie ist so viel zu
bomben- und das sehen wir an den
vergangenen tagen
momentan versucht er nicht mit truppen
hier rein zu kommen sondern mit
artillerie moerser angriffen und andere
hier für angst und schrecken zu sorgen
und das sieht man jeden morgen oder in
der nacht wir sind gestern nacht von
einer ganz lauten explosionen aufgewacht
hier um alle wände gewackelt und dann
haben wir den schaden gesehen der
sozusagen angerichtet wurde das passiert
in mariupol noch viel heftiger und in
weiteren städten noch viel heftiger
zurück zu deiner frage was kann man
jetzt tun
ich glaube dass der weg richtig der
ukraine zu verhandeln aber gleichzeitig
klar zu machen dass man die position die
wladimir putin zu beginn des krieges
bezogen hat nämlich die militarisierung
neutralität sozusagen der ukraine das
existenzrecht abzusprechen dass das
unmöglich ist natürlich ist das
unmöglich 2 der westen muss viel
entschlossener wirken und muss in den
sanktionen noch entschlossener erwähnten
aus meiner sicht und auch im auftreten
gegenüber putin und der frage wie man
mit den oligarchen umgeht und drittens
wir brauchen endlich jemanden der es
schafft die beiden an einen tisch zu
bekommen wladimir putin und selensky wir
haben gesehen wie die mission von
gerhard schröder kolossal gescheitert
ist andy roddick der ukrainische
botschafter hat schröder heute heftig
kritisiert dafür auch aus der ukraine
waren wir dass man gerhard schröder
vorwirft dort eine pr aktion zu seinen
gunsten gestartet zu haben also wenn es
mit gerd schröder nicht geklappt hat
dann frage ich mal in die runde wie wärs
mit angela merkel
vela can spyder angela merkel ja und das
haben wir bei ralf schuler so ein
bisschen daraus gehört ich hoffe dass
ich das nicht so richtig verstanden habe
also putin hat angegriffen weil rot-grün
in berlin regieren dann will ich mal
gerne die frage stellen wie wäre es mit
angela merkel gewesen wäre das anders
gewesen und zudem ich werde ihm gar
nicht ausweichen das vielleicht auch so
eine kleine provokation von paul denen
ich seit seiner berichterstattung auf
dem majdan sehr freundschaftlich
verbunden bin das ja auch schon ein paar
jahre her aber ich werde ihm gar nicht
ausweichen paul das kann ja sein dass
das die haltung die duh heute ja auch
schon im bild wiedergegeben ist die
haltung der ukrainischen regierung ist
und das muss man ja auch respektieren
ich bin ja auch bild leser und ich bin
auch arbeiten ganz kurz
als politiker leser
als politiker gehört ja gleich könnte
man da könnte man davon aus dass sich
springer verlag risiko und bei politiker
habe ich eine ganz andere interpretation
dieses treffens gelesen das nämlich gerd
schröder hier durchaus in kontakt in
engem kontakt war mit der ukrainischen
regierung angesprochen worden ist ich
habe mit ihm darüber nicht gesprochen
also ich weiß nicht welche version
richtig ist ich denke nur wenn sie zwei
ganz unterschiedliche versionen aus dem
gleichen verlag kommen dann sollte sich
der leser die eigene meinung bilden was
denn der richtige ist und was ein
bisschen übersteigert und da vielleicht
überinterpretiert solar gab es dann das
treffen aber es wäre ganz kurz da muss
ich einmal damals ja einmal nein ganz
kurz weil bilderseite seine
provokationen von mir das stimmt
überhaupt nicht es geht eigentlich nur
um die nachrichtenlage heute und die
darstellung sozusagen bis der der
nachrichtenlage hat nichts mit meiner
meinung zu tun also wenn du dir diesen
bericht durchliest dann siehst du dort
die zitate des ukrainischen botschaft
dass ich lese gern noch einmal vor die
an deutlichkeit
nichts vermissen lassen das hat ja
nichts mit meiner meinung zu tun sondern
dieser botschafter hat sich damit
auseinandergesetzt und er sagt zitat
über mittelsmänner wurde die ukrainische
seite aus erster hand informiert über
die ergebnisse der reise von den
schröder nach moskau und seines
gesprächs mit herrn putin auch wenn die
hoffnung auf diese persönliche
initiative von herrn schröder von anfang
an zu klein war ist die enttäuschung
trotzdem groß dass er wirklich gar
nichts konkretes oder hilfreiches zu
berichten hatte dieser vorstoß entpuppte
sich leider gottes als komplett
ergebnislos und wohl auch als sinnlos um
den barbarischen vernichtungs blick des
putin russlands gegen die ukrainische
zivilbevölkerung zu stoppen das ist sehr
bedauerlich die ukraine braucht dringend
ehrliche vermittler die uns helfen
können das schlimmste blutvergießen in
europa seit dem zweiten weltkrieg dass
putin und seine treuen schergen tag und
nacht anrichten und das unermessliche
leid der menschen so schnell wie möglich
zu beenden das ist das was ich zitiert
habe da geht es gar nicht um meine
meinung ich muss sagen bei der frage wer
diesen krieg beendet ist mir das völlig
egal wer dort vermittelt und auch wenn
ich bei version aufgrund seines
engagements mit gazprom
habe mit gerhard schröder wenn er dort
was geschafft hätte hätte ich ihm nur
gratulieren und das ist ja jetzt
momentan offenbar der stand wieder
gegeben von der ukrainischen seite ich
kann das nicht interpretieren ich kann
nur noch mal leider bis jetzt hier nicht
aber können ja jeder nachlesen was ja
zeitgleich heute auch noch mal von
politik über dieses gespräch berichtet
worden ist aus quellen wie ich nicht
kenne aber das weiß wohl politiker ein
sehr seriöses auch aus dem
springer-verlag kommendes medium das
offenbar andere quellen hat war es gar
nicht besser oder schlechter als du nur
das mal dahin gestellt und auch mir ich
glaube ich habe wurden die anonym hier
ist es geht ja auch mal das rasieren
oder war das nach polen ab die genannten
freuen dich denn journalist keine ja
aber du hast du hast vielleicht gelesen
du hast doch also allen die kollegen zu
januar wurde das ist ja ein unterschied
aber es ja aber ist ja ein unterschied
ob man anonym zitiert oder ob wir jetzt
über ein zitat des ukrainischen
botschaft das sprechen ist schon ein
unterschied wie gesagt ich will mir gar
nicht sagen dass das eine oder das
andere richtig ist nur das ist ja eine
klare aussage da weiß man wer es gesagt
hat und man kennt das zitat und da geht
es ja aber deswegen meine frage wie
kommen wir da jetzt raus also was muss
jetzt passieren also bild gerne schröder
noch was erreichen das ist ja eigentlich
gefragt du also mir ist glaube ich nicht
jeden geben nicht bei wahrscheinlich
nicht aber manchen anderen ist glaube
ich völlig egal wer da was erreicht
hauptsache es wird etwas darf man ob man
nach einem jahr nach einer einem einem
teil von verhandlungen schon von einem
endergebnis reden kann weiß ich auch
nicht vielleicht braucht man mehr zeit
hat keiner in dieser phase aber
vielleicht muss man gucken was da noch
kommt ich weiß es nicht ich will ja auch
mir nicht anmaßen hier irgendwie in die
welt zu setzen die andere frage ist noch
mal zurück wäre mit angela merkel das
nicht passiert denn das lieber als
schule habe ich so deinen äußerungen so
entnommen das wäre jetzt ein grobes
missverständnis denn die russlandpolitik
von angela merkel ist in meinen augen
auch gescheitert und zwar krachend
gescheitert immer wenn putin irgendwo
gezündelt hat bekam er zur belohnung
irgendein geschenkt damit er wieder
ruhig ist diese logik kann man nicht so
weiterführen schon gar nicht nach einem
angriffskrieg auf ein anderes land das
problem ist dass angela merkel auf eine
ziemlich blauäugige art und weise sorry
ich möchte kein r level immer die stärke
des rechts gepredigt hat und im
gegenteil zum recht des stärkeren was
wir immer vergessen haben das müssen wir
einfach ganz klar sagen auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich übrigens das ist
dass das recht von einer stärker
begleitet und durchgesetzt werden muss
und wer nur recht hat und nicht stark
genug ist das durchzusetzen der verliert
natürlich gegen den stärkeren das haben
wir immer irgendwie unterschätzt und
meine bemerkung zur ampel zielt
eigentlich auch nur darauf hin dass
natürlich die grünen und die spd nicht
das erste sind was ein zum punkte
wehrhaftigkeit ein feld also das ist
natürlich interne flügelkämpfe dass es
debatten geben wird sowas reise ein dass
ich total 400 milliarden euro ein wie
aber werden die gesichter der grünen
durfte man dabei nicht gucken in meinen
bundes osten und auch in der spd ist
dass ich jetzt nicht nur mit eitel
sonnenschein begrüßt worden also das zu
testen und herauszufordern für heute aus
meiner sicht schon sehr kühlem kalkül
scholz hat da mit einem donnerschlag
dagegen gehalten jetzt muss das
natürlich noch umgesetzt werden